i ain't really did no shows in l.a at
all yeah i feel like the roxy was the
last nah like hell no like
i think after that i did observatory the
last time i saw you was uh
i saw you at when you were at uh
before the pandemic at day in vegas
yeah in vegas and that was one of my
worst shows ever that was just a cool
moment because i want to say it was you
was it one take jay yeah
it was just a cool moment it was really
like a
yeah my boy capsule of like that was
like that i didn't even like that day i
didn't even go to sleep or not it was
like a worse show to me because i
couldn't even rap i was throw [ __ ] up
voice that's the first time i ever took
a [ __ ] euro
i took a euro it's like a xcp oh okay
okay i took it the night before and i
never went to sleep i ended up losing my
phone all type of crazy [ __ ]
i had to go on stage that next day was
it worth it
yeah it was fun yeah
i don't regret it i've never done any
sort of ecstasy i had south side from
ecstasy and you've never done no i've
only eaten
you ever done molly no what
weed and shrooms
where i come from a family of hardcore
drug addicts
no no shrooms is [ __ ] that's [ __ ]
from the earth that's medicine right
that's molly it's pure
try molly they say it's pure until you
end up [ __ ] on tmz because you
overdosed on a [ __ ] fentanyl laced
molly pill like yeah this is good
you got to get the tester right that's
why i stopped popping pills
because of that
were you like a pretty like were you
just like recreational with the pill
popping or was it like popping pills
i'm talking about
serious
popping pills
perk sex and everything
no no perk sex
so what was your pill of choice i have
tried them
uh actually
so you're telling me to try accessing
you stopped yourself i stopped it
because like you said
but i feel like you should have tried it
yes southside from 808 mafia offered me
one in the middle of our interview
hey that's my boy too he's you know what
he told me what he told me you're gonna
send me a beat i lost my [ __ ]
mind but that's cause he [ __ ] with the
homies from the other [ __ ] he's the
coolest [ __ ] like we have the
most hilarious
wild talk ever shout out to bro for real
shout out to bro and like
he's like really really uh
he pop x
oh yeah that's what's up yeah he does a
lot that's what i'll be saying like
sometimes like if you popped it you like
you get back in that mold sometimes like
he was talking about how he one time
like uh he would he's done ecstasy
thinking he was gonna [ __ ] a [ __ ] that
night
well listen and then didn't and then
ended up jacking off into the [ __ ]
sun came he said it was a longer jerk
not quite a better jerk but a longer
jerk nah [ __ ] jacking off multiple
times when you don't get no [ __ ] like
have you ever jerked off on ecstasy what
[ __ ] it'd be nice like when you really
think you'll get some or [ __ ] just you
just take a pill yeah and you really end
up in that bed by yourself it's all over
it man have you ever taken like a honey
pack or a rhino thinking
that she made my hair hurt the next day
yeah they do that for sure nah uh
rhino i took a rhino when i was young
yeah 18.
i just did it because just cause why not
you're at the gas station right this
should be good yeah and i did it that
[ __ ] was crazy did you did you
do it and then
hook up with a chick did you feel like
[ __ ] yeah a different thing yeah you
know what i'm saying but it's just like
performance enhancing it's like uh when
barry bonds started doing the roids like
he was already a good baseball player
with my dick to go down to like [ __ ]
eight in the morning 100 yeah the worst
part is is the weight you wake up with
the hardest erection ever [ __ ] can't
even pee in a toilet shooting
bro there's have you ever have you ever
you got a stance yeah you gotta you
gotta stand over the toilet bro that's
real
the piss boner baby bash would call it
the piss boner man bro yo shout out to
baby bash baby bastard always tell me
stories about how you'd wake up in the
morning and [ __ ] chick with his piss
boner
baby bad
damn hey see i knew all these [ __ ] be
living this crazy ass lifestyle bro baby
bad sugar sugar baby badge with you yeah
that's my guy man that's a wild boy
that's far